inizio condividendo con voi una frase
che per me ha rappresentato tantissimo
ed è questa il nostro benessere e la
nostra felicità dipendono dalla qualità
delle nostre relazioni
a quanto ammonta il tuo capitale sociale
ora io non lo so voi cosa rispondereste
ma vi assicuro che cinque anni fa il mio
capitale sociale era un disastro era
minimi storici
mi lamentavo in continuazione di non
avere il tempo di prendermi cura delle
cose importanti come ad esempio godermi
i primi mesi di vita di mia figlia
oppure di stare insieme alle persone che
amo e quindi questa frase per me ha
rappresentato l'inizio di una
riflessione molto profonda
alla fine del quale ho avuto bisogno e
ho sentito l'urgenza di cambiare quindi
ho scelto scelto di smettere di
lamentarmi oggi abbiamo capito perché è
così importante di smettere di
preoccuparmi del tempo e di occuparmi
del mio tempo
ed è così che ha iniziato il mio lavoro
intorno al capitale sociale
ed è così che ho iniziato la mia
attività di divulgatrice di studio di
ricerca il capitale sociale è diventato
un pilastro di quello che faccio e
quindi oggi io vorrei raccontarvi perché
è così importante perché le scienze ci
stanno dicendo che è importante per
farlo ve lo definisco un po meglio lo
avrete un po intuito il capitale sociale
è la capacità che ognuno di noi sa di
costruire la propria rete di relazioni
nell'arco di tutta la sua vita ed è una
rete che deve avere una qualità
specifica deve basarsi sulla fiducia si
basa su comportamenti quindi come
rispetto alla collaborazione il supporto
la gentilezza più noi investiamo su
questi comportamenti più questa rete
diventa forte pronta a sostenerci
momenti di difficoltà e questo lo avete
capito bene si chiama anche resilienza
ora perché è così importante ho
selezionato per voi
3 informazioni che la scienza ci mette a
disposizione e quindi vele racconto la
prima non si è evoluta la specie più
forte ma quella che ha saputo cooperare
di più
noi siamo cablati per la socialità
vedete
[Musica]
bastano 20 secondi
vi abbraccio per consentire al vostro
corpo di produrre ossitocina che è
l'ormone della fiducia e non solo si è
visto che la qualità delle nostre
relazioni determina la qualità del
nostro funzionamento fisiologico
migliore ad esempio il nostro sistema
immunitario cardiovascolare e neuro
endocrino consentendoci di riprenderci
prima nei traumi o nelle situazioni
complesse
questo lo si sta riscontrando in ogni
ambito di cura è fantastico seconda
informazione più frequente è di segno
positivo il rapporto che costruisco come
una persona più è forte il legame che il
nostro cervello crea con quella persona
ciò vuol dire che quella persona diventa
parte della nostra memoria viene
scolpita nella nostra rete neuronale
ed è per questo che se provate a pensare
quanto migliorerebbe la nostra vita se
ognuno di noi si facesse carico di
queste informazioni vendita pensarci
veramente se ogni insegnante portasse
questo concetto nella relazione con la
propria classe con i propri alunni
ogni imprenditore con i propri
collaboratori
oppure i medici con i suoi con i loro
pazienti alla loro équipe o un
amministratore pubblico con i propri
cittadini
la prima cosa che migliorerebbe la
nostra efficacia perché si è visto che
in un team in un gruppo che può essere
un aula o una comunità
quello che determina il successo e
l'efficacia non è quanti supereroe ci
sono all'interno ma quante persone sono
in grado di costruire questo capitale
sociale
c'è un ted rimanere in tema molto bello
di margaret è ferma vi consiglio di
andarlo a vedere si chiama super polli
non grazie e spiega molto bene quello
che vi sto appena raccontando
terza informazione si chiama effetto
buffering dovete immaginarlo come un
ombrello perché esattamente come un
ombrello il capitale sociale è in grado
di proteggere un'organizzazione una
comunità nei momenti di difficoltà
quindi è in grado di costruire
resilienza
se noi investiamo nella qualità delle
nostre relazioni ogni giorno quindi
momenti in periodi non sospetti questo
ci ritorna indietro in termini di
supporto quando non avremo bisogno
quando avremo bisogno di spiegare perché
non riusciamo a fare una cosa perché
siamo in difficoltà gli altri saranno
pronti ad aiutarci e adesso ce l'hanno
appena spiegato con l'esempio del
terremoto
allora se queste sono le informazioni
che la scienza ci sta mettendo a
disposizione che società stiamo
costruendo
stiamo incamerando questi principi anno
al nostro interno
ho preparato delle immagini per provare
a riflettere con voi
non pensate anche voi forse che stiamo
diventando fin troppo bravi a comunicare
attraverso uno schermo piuttosto che
guardarci negli occhi e quindi stiamo
perdendo la capacità di costruire di
attivare quella chimica di cui vi ho
parlato che ci fa tanto bene
e su questo stiamo educando i nostri
giovani non pensate che ci siano un po
troppe persone che continuano a credere
che i problemi degli altri non siano i
nostri problemi e che come comunità
non possiamo più continuare a rimanere a
guardare perché avremo a disposizione
abbiamo a disposizione tutte le risorse
per affrontare e risolvere i più grandi
problemi dell'umanità come la fame
eppure siamo ancora qui a chiederci ma
che si può fare
chissà
non pensate che ci siano ancora troppe
persone che pensano al mantra prima il
dovere e poi piacere come la fonte del
loro successo della loro efficacia
costringendosi a passare ufficio dalle 8
10 12 ore
misurando così la loro capacità di
essere efficaci ma non è così perché il
nostro cervello funziona al contrario
e che dire del fatto che siamo abituati
a pensare che ad una certa età
smettiamo di essere risorse e ci
trasformiamo i problemi da gestire
insomma stiamo diventando sempre più
bravi a guardare ciò che c'è in
superficie e no ad esplorare ciò che c'è
nel profondo
ora ovviamente questo non è il 100 per
cento della nostra realtà ma è una fetta
molto molto importante stiamo costruendo
società che funzionano al contrario
rispetto al principio di natura con il
quale siamo stati costruiti ma la buona
notizia c'è ed è che noi possiamo invece
di invertire questa rotta possiamo
invertirla attraverso una cosa molto
importante dobbiamo fare massa critica
cioè aumentare la quantità di persone
che è sempre più hanno accesso a queste
informazioni
perché in questo modo aumentando la loro
consapevolezza potranno permettersi di
scegliere e di essere esempio
ispirazione per altre persone è
difficile non è semplice ma è possibile
siamo di fronte a un cambiamento
culturale che per definizione è
complesso ma possiamo farlo
sono passati cinque anni da quando ho
letto quella frase anni intensi ricchi
di studio che mi hanno portato a fondare
appunto una società che si occupa di
scienza della felicità
e sapete qual è la cosa più bella che è
successa in questi cinque anni che
abbiamo costruito una rete di persone
noi li chiamiamo giani positivi che con
competenza professionalità e solidità
stanno portando coraggiosamente queste
informazioni nel loro contesto
nelle scuole nelle aziende nei luoghi di
lavoro negli ospedali è possibile
dobbiamo solo iniziare a farlo e quindi
visto che c'è bisogno di allenamento
adesso vi chiedo di allenarmi insieme a
me quindi vi chiedo di prendere i vostri
telefonini perché la tecnologia se usata
bene può essere sicuramente un valido
aiuto e di aprire whatsapp è scegliere
fate lo fate lo fate lo voglio vedere i
display che si accendono scegliete una
persona nella vostra rubrica e inviate
di questo messaggio che ha preparato per
voi
pronti
vai ti voglio bene e vorrei dirti che io
ci sarò sempre
fatelo po di cortisolo che vi gira in
corpo in mentre lo fate vi dico possono
verificarsi seguenti casi la persona
riceve il messaggio e dice risponde che
è successo che ho fatto che ai due
bevuto oppure hai sbagliato persona
questo è il peggiore se vi succede
non vi preoccupate solo indice di quanto
siamo poco allenati a fare tutto quanto
questo noi possiamo cambiare possiamo
allenarci dobbiamo solo scegliere di
iniziare e mantener fede a questo nostro
mantra nuovo voglio un mondo ad alto
capitale sociale
lo voglio per mia figlia stella e per
tutti i bambini e ragazzi che tra
qualche anno prenderanno in mano le
redini di questo paese perché sono
convinta come disse qualcuno più saggio
di me e prima di me che noi questo mondo
non l'abbiamo ereditato dai nostri
genitori ma l'abbiamo preso in prestito
dai nostri figli e stanno e quindi
restituirli
più sano diventiamo quindi capitalisti
di benessere
investiamo sul nostro capitale sociale
grazie